Not so good to have a low Iq.
You know,
people don't like the idea of Iq because it seems so arbitrary,
you know,
have a high Iq.
Well it's not like you deserve that.
Exactly.
It's your set up that way pretty much right from the beginning.
It's very,
very,
very stable.
You can make a high Iq person stupider.
Why?
You know,
not educating them up to the level of their possibility but taking someone who
has a low Iq and trying to raise that.
It's like if you can figure out how to do that,
well you know it's Nobel prize time for you because people have tried that a lot
and most recently with those,
you know Luminol Lumosity games and that sort of thing and the evidence that
those produce anything other than brilliant performances on the Lumosity game
itself is basically zero.
We haven't been able to figure out how to see cause I intelligence is a cross
domain phenomena and you can get really good in a single domain by practicing
like Matt and what you'd want is to practice like mad in a single domain and
hope that it generalizes to other domains.
That's the holy grail of intelligence increase.
It's like no,
no one's done it.
People claim it but the claims never hold up and people have been trying for a
long time to do it and they haven't been able to do it.
And
differences in Iq really make a difference.
You know,
I mean you guys,
average Iq is probably one 25 one 30 ad at one 15 you're at the 85th percentile
and and one 15 would barely get you going for,
for hard university one 30 you're probably graduate school material,
you know one 45 you're up there
at the range where you can probably do pretty much whatever you want.
Although as you get smarter,
the scatter between your abilities increase.
So you might have a very high verbal Iq but not be so good at mathematics or the
other way around.
But it's a massive contributor to lifetime success.
And I don't know what to do about that.
I mean,
why do smart people make more money?
Well,
they get to where the edge of production is faster.
So if you have a thousand people and you rank order them by Iq,
the smart people are going to come up with a new ideas first and they're going
to have more ideas and they're going to strategize better.
And you know,
with an Iq of 90 which is
15% of the population,
you think about that 15% of the population.
That's pretty much the threshold for reading instructions and being able to
follow them.
Okay.
So you know,
and our societies and Chris increasingly sophisticated.
So it's by no means obvious.
You know,
the Liberals think,
well the society is unfair because there's unemployment and the Conservatives
think while there's a job for everyone and,
but none of them think,
well,
there are massive,
massive,
massive differences in people's ability,
far greater than anyone realizes.
And that poses a structural problem.